all right if you've been feeling more
anxious since the pandemic hit you are
not alone according to the kaiser family
foundation about four in ten adult
americans have reported symptoms of
anxiety or depressive disorder during
the pandemic that's compared to around 1
in 10 between january and june of 2019.
wendy suzuki is the author of the new
book good anxiety harnessing the power
of the most misunderstood emotion it's
published by atria books an imprint of
simon schuster which is a division of
viacom cbs wendy suzuki is a professor
of neural science and psychology at new
york university good morning to you
i know you wrote this book you said
before the pandemic hit because of the
number of people
that have identified with having anxiety
talk to us about what that is the
different levels yeah and how it can be
a good thing right so before the
pandemic 90
of americans raised their hands and said
i suffer from anxiety that was stunning
this is what made me want to write this
book
and i realized we all needed a new way
to approach anxiety and i approached it
from an evolutionary perspective
evolutionarily anxiety and the
underlying physiological stress response
evolved to protect us protect us from
external dangers which is why it
increases our heart rate increases our
respiration and puts blood to our
muscles so that we can either run away
or fight those dangers in your book you
said we need to be able to fail and have
things not work out for us to really
appreciate when things do work yes and i
think about vlad he always says this
quote thankful for the pain yes you have
to almost experience it to know how to
work through it yeah and then you talk
to them in the book about how to control
that anxiety right right and you've hit
upon a really important element that i
think people don't appreciate that is we
are humans beings with a huge array of
emotions not just the happy ones but all
the uncomfortable ones too right so part
of the message of this book is can you
appreciate the value the knowledge and
the wisdom that comes from looking in on
what those uncomfortable emotions tell
you about yourself what is going well in
your life what you value in your life
go ahead
just say how when you have all of this
yeah so you say can be good it can be
bad how do you go about managing some of
this anxiety yeah so that's a great
that's a great question and you manage
it first by first realizing my anxiety
doesn't feel protective for me right now
how can it be protective and it's not
protective because too much of anything
even a good thing is bad and so we all
collectively have too high level of
anxiety we want to first learn to dial
it down you can do that very simply by
breathing deeply which physiologically
activates our relaxation reflex i see
you're doing it right now
yoga breath i didn't realize how
important that was it really is later in
life yeah breathing just breathing that
is the most powerful immediate way we
can do we can decrease our anxiety
there's a whole list of tools that i
provide in the book but the second step
once you get that anxiety down is to do
what i was just saying turn inward start
to
examine what those uncomfortable
emotions associated with anxiety are
telling you about how you're living your
life what you value but then the third
element is that once you get that
managed and start to learn more about
your anxiety you start to be able to
develop what i call gifts or superpowers
from anxiety so
that is that is the secret so what is
the superpower that one can develop yeah
if we are confronted with anxiety yeah
so let me give you my top three number
one
turning to a superpower of productivity
and this is using that what if list that
comes with your anxiety it hits me right
before i'm going to go to sleep at night
what if this what if that and you turn
that into a to-do list so you bring an
action component to it which helps
resolve that anxiety and it makes a
superpower of productivity or a gift of
productivity number two is the gift of
flow so typically anxiety just cuts off
that flow you have no possibility of
flow but i've come up with the concept
of micro flow and i came up with this in
a yoga class when i was flowing in
shavasana i flow in shavasana i do it so
well and it's about appreciating those
small moments in your day where you do
have flow that can contrast with those
difficult moments and really quickly
when should people seek help yeah when
the breathing and exercising and looking
at and writing things down isn't enough
yeah so that's a great question so it is
when you get to the level of overwhelm
it prevents you from doing anything
productive in your life that's when you
should seek professional help but this
book is really for the rest of us
suffering from everyday anxiety which is
close to ninety percent of it
definitely affects a lot of people wendy
thank you so much
good anxiety it goes on sale tomorrow
make sure you pick it up